[Music]
so i don't know very much about
mormonism and by very much i mean
basically nothing so can you give me a
brief background about what that
uh religion is because i feel like
sometimes it's equated with other
religions that it shouldn't be sure yeah
i think the
like classic idea that people tend to
conjure up when
they hear the word mormon is like people
with bonnets
working in fields of pay with eight
wives
um latter-day saints like modern
mormonism is not that at all
uh in the past that was like an old
custom i guess to try and
get more kids out there they say um
sure but but now it's like it's very
much you marry one person you
get married quite young and you have as
many kids as you possibly can
and then the it's a lot of like basic
christianity basic christian principles
i would just say it's like heightened
and then there are a lot more rules that
go with it like you can't have caffeine
you can't have hot beverages
oh buy anything on sundays you there's
just like a million and a half rules
that are very hard to remember and even
harder to stand by
yeah well so if you can't have caffeine
that would be no to alcohol
absolutely no alcohol yeah no no tattoos
no you have to wear garments under your
clothes every day
i don't know what th there's some
there's like reason reasons behind all
of it that i'm not
that i don't remember i just remember
all the rules because growing up with an
anxiety disorder it
gave me a lot of anxiety to be like oh
how am i gonna do all this and not
do that
okay so how did somebody so say your mom
because you said your mom kind of
pushed you into acting does that kind of
how did that work with being a mormon
that's a good question not well um
but my mom would find like my mom was
the master of finding justifications for
the things that she wanted to be a
certain way
for example like it was really shunned
on
in the church when i played a child
prostitute
like no sister huff meyer wasn't having
it but my mom
would come to church and like have this
testimony speech
written where she would then go stand up
on the stage and talk about how like
this is actually a really good thing for
the church because it might lead to
prostitutes hearing the whisper of the
holy ghost if they see this
and they know that jeanette's mormon
like they might convert as well
that was the level of like wow scream
that my mom would take it
and somehow like looking back on it now
it seems ridiculous and absurd and over
the top
but at the time she would somehow like
persuade people
that that was reality and that that was
a good thing like she had a really
charming kind of side to her personality
even though she was saying
insane things most of the time well
sounds like she might have been a smart
cookie
to weave those kind of things together
you know she had a capacity for
intelligence and i feel like it was
wasted and i feel like she didn't really
use it for good and
it upsets me